Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Meanwhile, away from Rome, a highly respected senator by the name of Aulus Plautius embarked on an expedition against Britain. For a certain native of the island called Bericus, who had been forced into exile by a coup against him, had persuaded Claudius to send an army against the Britons. So it was that Plautius prepared to launch his invasion, but when he commanded his soldiers
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。与此同时，在罗马之外，一位名叫奥卢斯·普劳蒂乌斯（Aulus Plautius）的受人尊敬的元老率领远征军前往不列颠。因为岛上的一个本地人贝里库斯（Bericus）因一场针对他的政变而被流放，他曾说服克劳狄（Claudius）派遣军队讨伐不列颠人。于是，普劳蒂乌斯准备发动入侵，然而当他命令士兵
to embark and set sail from Gaul, they refused. The reason for this was the dread they felt at the thought of undertaking a campaign beyond the limits of the known world, and they remained in a state of open mutiny until Narcissus, one of Claudius' former slaves who had been sent to their camp by the emperor, climbed up onto the tribunal and sought to address them. At this, they became so indignant that they would not allow Narcissus to say a single word until suddenly as one they began to chant the phrase Io Saturnalia for as everyone knows slaves dress up as their masters during the festival of the Saturnalia and everything is turned upside down and with that the mutiny was ended and the soldiers willingly followed Plautius to Britain. So that, Tom, was Cassius Dio writing
登船并从高卢起航时，他们拒绝了。原因是他们一想到要跨越已知世界的尽处进行远征，心中便充满了恐惧，他们公开哗变，直到克劳狄的前奴隶之一纳尔基苏斯（Narcissus）——被皇帝派往他们的军营——登上法庭并试图向他们讲话。对此，他们感到无比愤怒，甚至不允许纳尔基苏斯说哪怕一个字，突然间，他们齐声高呼“农神节快乐”（Io Saturnalia），因为众所周知，在农神节期间，奴隶们会扮成主人的模样，一切都颠倒了过来。就这样，哗变平息了，士兵们心甘情愿地跟随普劳蒂乌斯前往不列颠。汤姆，那是卡西乌斯·狄奥（Cassius Dio）在
a long time after Claudius's invasion of Britain in AD 43. So in the last episode, we did Julius Caesar and his landing, the first date in recorded history, as I think everybody agrees. The second most important date in history. This is all very mysterious, probably to a lot of our listeners, all this sort of shouting about the Saturnalia and stuff. What is going on? So we have moved on almost a century. The context is now totally different.
克劳狄于公元43年入侵不列颠很久之后所写的记录。所以在上一集中，我们讲了尤利乌斯·恺撒（Julius Caesar）及其登陆，这是有据可查的历史上的第一个日期，我想大家都这么认为。这是历史上第二重要的日期。对于我们的许多听众来说，这可能非常神秘，大家都在大声喊着关于农神节之类的事情。这到底是怎么回事？所以我们已经向前推进了几乎一个世纪。背景现在完全不同了。
We're into the empire. Claudius is the emperor. People remember Claudius. You've seen the TV show, I, Claudius, or read Robert Graves' novels. And the context, the political context is so different because Rome is an autocracy now and not a competitive republic. Yeah. And I think that the change between the age of Caesar and Claudius, so it's a century pretty much, is best summed up by the way that the Latin word imperator has evolved. So in Caesar's time, imperator means a general, a victorious general. If you win a victory, your soldiers hail you as imperator. By the time of Claudius, it's coming to take on
我们已经进入了帝国时期。克劳狄是皇帝。大家都记得克劳狄。你看过电视剧《我，克劳狄》（I, Claudius），或者读过罗伯特·格雷夫斯（Robert Graves）的小说。而且背景，政治背景是如此不同，因为罗马现在是一个独裁政体，而不是一个竞争性的共和国。是的。我认为，从恺撒时代到克劳狄时代的转变——差不多是一个世纪——最好通过拉丁语单词 imperator 的演变来概括。所以在恺撒的时代，imperator 意为将军，一位胜利的将军。如果你赢得了胜利，你的士兵就会欢呼你为 imperator。到了克劳狄时期，它开始承载
the connotations of the English word emperor, which of course derives from the Latin word imperator. And this reflects the fact that the Roman empire now has a single figure at its head. This is reflection of the great revolution that's been achieved by Caesar's adopted son, his great nephew, Augustus Caesar. And the consequence of this is that the Roman Empire is even more formidable than it had been in Caesar's day. So it's hugely expanded. It's about twice the size that it was back in Caesar's time. It has this incredible innovation, which is professional armies, which the figure of Caesar stands at the head. So there's a very clear chain of command.
英语单词 emperor（皇帝）的内涵，这个词当然源自拉丁语 imperator。这反映了一个事实：罗马帝国现在有一位独裁者处于最高领导地位。这反映了恺撒的养子、他的侄孙奥古斯都·恺撒（Augustus Caesar）所取得的伟大革命。而其结果是，罗马帝国比恺撒时代更加强大。它的规模大大扩张了。它的面积大约是恺撒时代的两倍。它拥有一项不可思议的创新，即常备专业军队，而恺撒的形象就站在其顶端。因此，这里有着非常清晰的指挥链。
And it has a very aggressive public ideology, which is essentially that the Romans have the right to conquer anywhere they like. Empire without limits is what Virgil called it. But despite that fact, although under Augustus there had been a lot of conquest, as I said, under his two heirs, so first Tiberius, who had been his adopted son, and then Caligula, who had been his great-grandson. So that's why they come to rule, because both those two emperors have the mystique of Augustus. Despite that, there hasn't actually been any major campaigns of conquest. And I think there's a sense in the Roman high command, in the capital, that the empire has reached its natural limits, that it's bounded by deserts, by barbarians,
它拥有非常激进的公共意识形态，其核心本质是罗马人有权征服他们喜欢的任何地方。“无界帝国”正是维吉尔（Virgil）对它的称呼。但尽管如此，虽然在奥古斯都统治下有过大量的征战，正如我所说，在他的两个继承人——首先是曾被他收养的养子提比略（Tiberius），然后是曾是他的曾孙的卡利古拉（Caligula）统治下也是如此。这就是他们得以统治的原因，因为这两位皇帝都带有奥古斯都的光环。尽管如此，实际上并没有进行过任何大规模的征服战役。我认为罗马高层和首都有一种感觉，即帝国已经达到了它的自然极限，它被沙漠和野蛮人所包围，
it's not worth conquering, or of course, by the ocean ocean so the question then tom given that in the last episode we said that apart from slaves and oysters i think it wasn't and a few pearls and i should have mentioned hunting dogs and hunting dogs and hoodies as well hoodies yeah britain's very well known for its hoodies as in people are wearing hoodies yeah okay that Okay, that's nice. Cloaked. Right. You know, hooded cloaks. So apart from those things, which, to be honest, in the grand scheme of things, if you're ruling the Roman Empire with the enormous wealth of the Mediterranean and of Egypt, what's now Turkey, Asia Minor, and so on, these things are pretty small beer. Why would anybody launch an invasion of Britain at all? Well, I think it's because Claudius has come to power very recently and he is very concerned to establish himself as a genuine imperator in both senses of the word. So as an emperor and as a general. And he wants to establish himself as an emperor
不值得去征服，当然，或者被茫茫大洋所阻。那么问题来了，汤姆，鉴于我们在上一集中说过，除了奴隶和牡蛎——我想当时还有一些珍珠，我本来还应该提到猎犬，还有连帽斗篷，连帽斗篷，是的，不列颠以其连帽斗篷而闻名，也就是人们穿的连帽斗篷，好的，好吧，那很好。带风帽的斗篷。对。你知道的，带风帽的斗篷。所以除了这些东西之外，说实话，从宏观的角度来看，如果你统治着拥有地中海和埃及、现在的土耳其、小亚细亚等地巨额财富的罗马帝国，这些东西实在是微不足道。为什么还会有人发起对不列颠的入侵呢？嗯，我认为这是因为克劳狄最近刚刚掌权，他非常渴望将自己确立为这两个意义上真正的统帅（imperator）。既作为皇帝，又作为将军。他希望将自己确立为皇帝
because he cannot cast himself as a son of Augustus, as Tiberius and Caligula had been able to do. He has come to power in a coup. And although he's been raised in the imperial family, this is because he is the grandson of Augustus's wife, Livia. And Livia had been married to a Claudius before she married Augustus. And this is why Claudius has been raised in the bosom of Augustus's household. You why Claudius has been raised in the bosom of Augustus's household. You know, he kind of needs to establish his legitimacy, but he needs to establish his legitimacy as a general, as well as an emperor, because he hasn't had any military experience, but also he hasn't had any experience of being in a position of authority at all.
因为他无法把自己包装成奥古斯都的儿子，就像提比略和卡利古拉所能做的那样。他是通过政变上台的。尽管他是在帝国家族中抚养长大的，但这只是因为他是奥古斯都的妻子莉维娅（Livia）的孙子。莉维娅在嫁给奥古斯都之前曾嫁给过一个克劳狄。这就是为什么克劳狄是在奥古斯都的家庭核心中抚养长大的。你知道的，他某种程度上需要确立自己的合法性，但他更需要确立自己作为将军以及皇帝的合法性，因为他没有任何军事经验，而且他也完全没有任何担任过权力职位的经验。
His elder brother, a very kind of dashing man who gets the name Germanicus because of his campaigns in Germany, he's the great idol of the Roman people. He dies young, like kind of Princess Diana. It's kind of mass public effusions. So if Claudius had been like Germanicus, there wouldn't really be a problem. But he hadn't been for reasons that everyone who's seen like Claudius or read the books by Robert Graves will know that Claudius, he dribbles, he snorts snot out through his nose, he stammers, he has a limp, and he's seen by his own mother as well as by everyone else as an absolute idiot. So for that reason, he hasn't been given any public responsibilities at all. So he doesn't have a track record that he can use to kind of buttress his authority as an emperor. In fact, he's not
他的长兄是一个非常潇洒的人，因为在日耳曼的战役而被称为日耳曼尼库斯（Germanicus），他是罗马人民的巨大偶像。他很年轻就去世了，有点像戴安娜王妃。这引发了一种大众的情感倾泻。所以如果克劳狄像日耳曼尼库斯那样，就不会有什么真正的问题了。但他不是，原因所有看过《我，克劳狄》或读过罗伯特·格雷夫斯书籍的人都知道：克劳狄会流口水，他吸着鼻涕，他结巴，他跛行，他被自己的母亲以及其他所有人视为一个绝对的白痴。正因如此，他根本没有被赋予任何公共职责。所以他没有任何可以用来支撑他作为皇帝威严的政绩。事实上，他一点也不
stupid at all. He's very smart. He's very competent. He's quite a scholar. But his style of administration, it doesn't seem heroic to most Romans. He's grown up surrounded by women and by freedmen. And as emperor, he relies on them because of course, freedmen are appointed to run the treasury or whatever, because they're very, very competent. But people don't want to believe, you know, freeborn Romans don't want to feel that former slaves have positions of authority over them. Like Narcissus in that opening reading. Absolutely. So it's absolutely classic of Claudius that, you know, he's informed there's a mutiny and he should send a freed person to try and sort it out. And really, I mean, he's kind of lucky the mutiny ends the way that it does. But people may also
愚蠢。他非常聪明。他非常能干。他是个学者。但他的行政风格在大多数罗马人看来并不显得英雄气概。他在女人和解放奴隶（freedmen）的环绕中长大。作为皇帝，他依赖他们，当然，解放奴隶被任命去管理国库或诸如此类的事情，因为他们非常、非常能干。但人们不愿意相信，你知道的，生而自由的罗马人不希望觉得前奴隶在他们头上拥有权力的职位。就像开篇阅读中的纳尔基苏斯那样。绝对是的。因此，这完全是克劳狄式的经典作风，你知道的，当有人通知他发生了哗变，而他应该派一个解放奴隶去试图解决它。而且说实话，我的意思是，他有点走运，哗变以那种方式结束了。但人们可能也会
be wondering, why has there been a mutiny? There hadn't been a mutiny when Caesar led his armies across the ocean, and that was the first Roman invasion of Britain. And I think the reason for that is that in the intervening century between Caesar's invasion and Claudius' invasion, two major disasters have happened that cast very, very long shadows over the imaginations of everyone who is contemplating an invasion of Britain. And the first of these had happened 34 years previously in AD 9. And that's the annihilation of three legions beyond the Rhine. And that's the Varus, the Teutoburg Forest under Augustus.
在想，为什么会发生哗变？当恺撒率领他的军队跨越大洋时并没有发生哗变，那是罗马对不列颠的第一次入侵。我想原因在于，在恺撒入侵和克劳狄入侵之间的一个世纪里，发生了两场重大灾难，在所有考虑入侵不列颠的人的心中投下了非常、非常长久的阴影。其中第一场发生在34年前的公元9年。那就是莱茵河外的三个军团被全歼。那是奥古斯都统治下的条顿堡森林之战，瓦鲁斯（Varus）的全军覆没。
The Varian disaster. And this had been against the backdrop of an attempt by the Romans to establish a province across the Rhine in Germany. These three legions get wiped out and essentially the Roman occupation force withdraws to behind the Rhine. So that is a huge disaster that everyone is aware of. The other one happens seven years later in 1816, and it happens under the aegis of Germanicus, who's been leading reprisal campaigns against the Germans who had destroyed Varus. And he sets sail into the North Sea on a great fleet and a storm hits this fleet and absolutely destroys it. And Germanicus himself only survives with great difficulty. And actually, the disaster is so great that he has to be restrained from committing suicide.
瓦鲁斯的灾难。这是在罗马人试图在日耳曼的莱茵河对岸建立一个行省的背景下发生的。这三个军团被消灭了，基本上罗马的占领军撤退到了莱茵河后方。所以这是一场每个人都知道的巨大灾难。另一场发生在七年后的公元16年，发生在日耳曼尼库斯的庇护下，他一直在领导针对消灭了瓦鲁斯的日耳曼人的报复战役。他率领庞大的舰队驶入北海，一场风暴袭击了这舰队并彻底摧毁了它。日耳曼尼库斯本人也是历经千难万险才幸存下来。事实上，这场灾难如此巨大，以至于人们不得不阻止他自杀。
And you can see why the thought of crossing the ocean and landing in a place where they might be cut off and is full of completely terrifying barbarians would be a shadow because there's a sense that the Britons are even more barbarous than the Germans. Because of their blueness, their moustaches, drinking milk, and other deviant behaviours, as I believe the jargon now has it. Women are supposed to strip off and paint themselves black. I mean, all kinds of terrible things. So I think that that anxiety about the dimension of the supernatural that we talked about in the context of Caesar's expedition has grown and grown and grown. And the reason for this is that every Roman soldier knows what had happened to prisoners that were captured by the Germans
你能理解为什么一想到要横渡大洋并在一个他们可能被切断退路且充满完全可怕的野蛮人的地方登陆，就会成为挥之不去的阴影，因为人们有一种感觉，不列颠人比日耳曼人还要野蛮。因为他们涂着蓝色颜料、留着八字胡、喝牛奶以及其他变态行为，我相信现在的行话就是这么说的。据说女人们会脱光衣服，把自己涂成黑色。我的意思是，各种各样可怕的事情。所以我觉得，我们在恺撒远征的背景下讨论过的关于超自然维度的焦虑，已经日复一日、不断地增长、增长、再增长。其原因在于，每一个罗马士兵都知道日耳曼人在公元9年
in AD 9, that they were sacrificed to the German gods, that they were drowned in bogs, that they were taken into woods, that they were hanged from oak trees, that they were beheaded, that they had unspeakable tortures inflicted on them, offered up essentially as sacrifices to the gods. And they also have a sense that the storms that destroyed the Roman fleet, again, this had, you know, it's almost like something from Greek mythology that sailors who came back, soldiers who were shipwrecked and were returned to Roman territory, reported having seen terrible sea monsters, sea monsters of ambiguous form between man and beast and strange birds. So I think there's a sense that Britain isn't just barbarous, it's demon haunted.
对所俘虏的囚犯做过什么：他们被当作祭品献给日耳曼诸神，他们在沼泽中被淹死，他们被带进树林，被吊在橡树上，被斩首，他们遭受了无法言说的酷刑，本质上作为祭品献给诸神。他们也有一种感觉，即摧毁罗马舰队的风暴——这再次几乎像是希腊神话中的情节——那些回来的水手、遭遇海难并返回罗马领土的士兵，报告说他们看到了可怕的海怪，那些介于人和野兽之间形态模糊的海怪以及奇怪的鸟类。所以我觉得人们有一种感觉，不列颠不仅野蛮，而且闹鬼。
And this reputation that Britain has as being not just a place where magic is very strong, but the home of magic is something that endures even after the invasion has been launched. So Pliny writing about 30 years later, he writes about Britain that magic to this very day holds it in its shadow. But Tom, how is this different from 100 years previously? The context for Caesar's invasion was slightly different in that those two disasters, the Teutoburg Forest and the disaster of the fleet, that they hadn't happened. But why are they not similarly anxious about magic and all that stuff?
而不列颠不仅是一个魔法非常强大的地方，而且是魔法的发源地，这种名声甚至在入侵发起之后依然长存。因此，大约30年后写作的普林尼（Pliny）写到不列颠时说，直到今天，魔法仍然将其笼罩在阴影之中。但是，汤姆，这与100年前有什么不同？恺撒入侵的背景略有不同，因为那两场灾难——条顿堡森林之战和舰队灾难——当时还没有发生。但为什么他们对魔法之类的事情没有同样的焦虑呢？
Or are they? Back in Caesar's day, they weren't sure about Britain's reputation. And that has grown over the succeeding decades, in part actually because of Caesar's campaigns and his commentaries. Because Caesar fighting in Gaul had written about a cadre of priests who had practiced human sacrifice, Caesar writes. And these same priests, their home is seen as being Britain. And in Britain, it is said, you know, they practice these unspeakable rites of sacrifice in kind of oaken groves festooned with mistletoe. And these priests are the Druids. But am I not right in thinking the Druids don't actually exist? Am I giving too much
或者说他们有？回到恺撒的时代，他们对不列颠的名声并不确定。而在随后的几十年里，这种名声有所增长，部分原因实际上是因为恺撒的战役和他的《高卢战记》。因为恺撒在与高卢人作战时，曾写到一个从事人祭的祭司阶层，恺撒写道。而这些祭司的大本营被认为是不列颠。据说在不列颠，你知道的，他们在挂满槲寄生的橡树林里进行这些无法言说的人祭仪式。这些祭司就是德鲁伊（Druids）。但我认为德鲁伊实际上并不存在，我的想法对吗？我是不是在这里剧透太多了？
away there? I mean, the Druids do exist. I mean, I don't think there's any doubt about that. The Romans report on them in such detail that it's impossible to think that they just made them up. It's true that we have no artefacts, no physical evidence actually proving the existence of Druids. But I think one of the things that suggests they did exist is the fact that Roman attitudes to them are actually very ambivalent. So there is a whole tradition in not just Romans, Greeks as well, looking on Druids as kind of philosophers, great natural scientists. So Cicero, who we mentioned in the previous episode, the great orator, he actually meets with a Druid, a man called Deviciacus in Rome, and is hugely impressed by him. He says he knows all about astronomy and philosophy and
我的意思是，德鲁伊是存在的。我的意思是，我认为对此毫无疑问。罗马人对他们的报道如此详细，以至于不可能认为他们是凭空捏造的。诚然，我们没有文物，没有实际的物理证据来证明德鲁伊的存在。但我认为，暗示他们确实存在的事实之一是，罗马人对他们的态度实际上非常矛盾。因此，不仅是罗马人，希腊人也有一种传统，将德鲁伊视为某种哲学家、伟大的自然科学家。所以我们在上一集提到过的伟大演说家西塞罗（Cicero），他实际上在罗马会见了一位名叫德维西亚库斯（Deviciacus）的德鲁伊，并对他印象深刻。他说他对天文学和哲学无所不知，
he can tell the future. He's absolutely brilliant. But others see them as the epitome of everything that is dark and sinister and demonic. They see them as kind of terrifying necromancers. Are they burning people in wicker men, Tom? Is that correct? Right. So that is a story that Caesar reports. And Caesar's reports absolutely embody this ambivalence that the Romans feel about Druids. So on the one hand, Diviciacus, the guy who goes to Rome, he's doing this as an ally and a friend of Caesar. Caesar respects and admires him. On the other hand, Caesar is saying the Druids round up criminals and put them in these vast
而且他能预知未来。他绝对是个天才。但其他人则认为他们是一切黑暗、阴险和妖魔化的化身。他们认为他们是可怕的死灵法师。汤姆，他们在柳条人（wicker men）中活活烧死人吗？这是真的吗？对。那是恺撒报道的一个故事。而恺撒的报道绝对体现了罗马人对德鲁伊的这种矛盾心理。一方面，去罗马的那个人德维西亚库斯，他是作为恺撒的盟友和朋友去那里的。恺撒尊重并钦佩他。另一方面，恺撒说德鲁伊把罪犯抓起来，把他们关在这些巨大的
wicker men. You know, if they find any policemen, they'll put them in there as well. Yeah, all that kind of thing. Edward Woodward. Yeah. You find him, he's straight in. I think what happens in the wake of the occupation of Gaul is that attitudes in Rome harden towards the Druids. They come to be seen as subversive. They're impressive figures and they are agitators against Roman rule and that makes them dangerous. And so Tiberius, who succeeds Augustus as emperor,
柳条人里。你知道的，如果他们发现任何警察，他们也会把他们塞进去。是的，诸如此类的事情。爱德华·伍德华（Edward Woodward）。对。你找到他，他马上就被塞进去了。我认为在高卢被占领之后发生的事情是，罗马对德鲁伊的态度变得强硬起来。他们开始被视为颠覆分子。他们是令人印象深刻的人物，也是反抗罗马统治的煽动者，这使得他们很危险。因此，继奥古斯都之后成为皇帝的提比略，
orders their suppression. The idea that Romans tolerate all gods isn't true. They come to see the Druids as being exceedingly dangerous, and they are wiped out across Gaul. But in Britain, of course, the Druids are still there. The long arm of Roman law doesn't reach across the channel. You can see why an anxiety about Britain as a land of sorcery and magic blurs into an anxiety about Britain as a land where you are likely to be captured and tortured to death and have your entrails hung over oak and glades. I wouldn't want to get on a ship if that was what I was kind of worrying about. Now you asked, is it true? Were there druids? So I'll quote you Ronald Hutton,
下令压制他们。罗马人包容所有神灵的观点并非事实。他们开始认为德鲁伊极其危险，他们在整个高卢被消灭了。但在不列颠，德鲁伊当然还在那里。罗马法律的长臂无法跨越海峡。你可以理解为什么对不列颠作为巫术和魔法之地的焦虑，会演变成对不列颠作为一个你很可能会被俘虏、折磨至死并将内脏挂在橡树林里的地方的焦虑。如果这就是我所担心的事情，我是绝不会上船的。现在你问，这是真的吗？真的有德鲁伊吗？所以我引述罗纳德·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）的话给你听，
who did two episodes we did on pagan Britain, very much a friend of the show. So he says, the Druids were the leading experts in religion, magic, and other matters concerning the supernatural among the Iron Age peoples of Northwestern Europe who spoke Celtic languages, including the British. And that is all that can be said about them with absolute certainty. So I think Ronald Hutton is incredibly sceptical. And if he says that they existed, then I think you can accept that they did. But I think what you can add to that is that the Romans did see them as being politically dangerous. And that's why they're targeted for extirpation.
他曾做过我们关于异教不列颠的两集节目，非常支持本节目。所以他说：“在说凯尔特语的西北欧铁器时代人们（包括不列颠人）当中，德鲁伊是宗教、魔法以及其他涉及超自然事物的主要专家。”关于他们，能够绝对确定地说出的也就只有这些了。所以我认为罗纳德·赫顿极其怀疑。如果他说他们存在，那么我认为你可以接受他们确实存在。但我认为你可以补充的一点是，罗马人确实认为他们在政治上是危险的。这就是为什么他们被作为铲除的目标。
And it's clear the Romans did also believe that they were practising human sacrifice. Now, Hutton in his book Pagan Britain which is brilliant and all this he's very skeptical about this the idea that Druids were actually practicing human sacrifice and he says well the Romans said this about the Jews or the Christians and we don't tend to think that they practice human sacrifice exactly but that's the counter view because the Romans said the Carthaginians practiced human sacrifice and archaeological evidence suggests that they did. And likewise, if we look at 16th century history, the Aztecs did practice sacrifice. Right. So just because people say it doesn't mean that it's not true. Yeah. But it kind of highlights the difficulty we have in making sense of the
而且很明显，罗马人也确实相信他们在实行人祭。现在，赫顿在他的著作《异教不列颠》（Pagan Britain）中——这本书很棒，讲了所有这些——对德鲁伊实际上在进行人祭的观点非常怀疑，他说，嗯，罗马人对犹太人或基督徒也这么说，而我们往往不认为他们会进行人祭，确实如此，但这是反观点，因为罗马人说迦太基人实行人祭，而考古证据表明他们确实如此。同样，如果我们看看16世纪的历史，阿兹特克人确实实行过人祭。对。所以，仅仅因为人们这么说并不意味着它不是真的。是的。但这某种程度上突显了我们在理解
Roman conquest of Britain is that, you know something so fundamental, you have to say, is probably not proven. Although, I mean, to give people a spoiler, I think they probably did human sacrifice in moments of particular stress and danger. And on the sacrifice issue, just before we move on, is it the case, as with your example about the 16th century, the Spanish and the Mexica, is it the case that the Romans are using the human sacrifice thing as a kind of bit of liberal interventionism from them? And this is one of their pretexts. It is. So they're going over there, they're stopping human sacrifice, taking prisoners and bringing them back to fight as gladiators in the arena.
罗马征服不列颠时所面临的困难，那就是，你知道如此基本的事情，你不得不说，可能尚未得到证实。虽然，我的意思是，为了给听众剧透一下，我认为他们在特别压力和危险的时刻可能确实进行了人祭。而在祭祀问题上，在我们继续之前，是否就像你关于16世纪西班牙人和墨西加人的例子一样，罗马人是在把人祭的事情当作他们的一种自由干涉主义（liberal interventionism）？这也是他们的借口之一。是的。所以他们去那里，他们制止人祭，俘虏囚犯并将他们带回竞技场作为角斗士战斗。
Well, that's a definite progressive change, isn't it? It is. It's progressive imperialism at its best. So one of the paradoxes of all this, this growing sense of Britain as a terrifying place of darkness and magic, is that actually, over the centuries, we were talking about at the end of the previous episode, the British tribes in the southeast of Britain, in the lowlands, have actually become increasingly integrated into the networks of Roman rule and of Roman trade. And as we also mentioned, they are no longer entirely prehistoric. And this is the form of these remarkable coins that have the names of British rulers stamped on them. And I know you're not a great man for an ancient coin, Dominic. No, I love coins, Tom. Do you? You're quite mistaken. I love ancient coins.
嗯，那绝对是一个进步的改变，不是吗？是的。这是处于最佳状态的进步帝国主义。因此，这一切的悖论之一，即不列颠作为黑暗与魔法的恐怖之地的这种日益增长的感觉，实际上是，几个世纪以来——我们在上一集的末尾讨论过——不列颠东南部、低地地区的不列颠部落，实际上已经越来越融入罗马统治和罗马贸易的网络中。正如我们还提到的那样，他们不再完全是史前时期。这就是这些刻有不列颠统治者名字的非凡硬币的形式。我知道你对古代硬币不是很感冒，多米尼克。不，我喜欢硬币，汤姆。是吗？你完全误解了。我喜欢古代硬币。
Okay. So you must have seen these British coins. They're beautiful. They're kind of abstract. They're weird. They have a kind of strange physical quality that you can angle them and you will see new things. So it may look purely abstract when you look at it one way, but you'd angle it another way and suddenly you see a kind of face. And there's a wonderful description of them by Duncan McKay, who's written a superb book on Boudicca called Echolands, which I'll be quoting a lot in our next episode on Boudicca. It came out last year and it's the best book on Roman Britain I've read in ages. And I highly recommend it to everyone. And he describes these coins beautifully. He calls them little tabs of hallucinatory braille, which I absolutely love. I mean, anyone who's touched one will immediately recognize what he means. And ultimately, these coins derive not from the Romans, but from the Greeks,
好吧。那你一定见过这些不列颠硬币。它们很漂亮。它们有点抽象，有点怪异。它们有一种奇怪的物理质感，你可以改变角度，就会看到新的东西。所以当你从一个角度看时，它可能纯粹是抽象的，但当你从另一个角度调整时，你会突然看到一张脸。邓肯·麦凯（Duncan McKay）对它们进行了绝妙的描述，他写了一本关于布狄卡（Boudicca）的出色著作《回声之地》（Echolands），我将在我们下一集关于布狄卡的节目中大量引用它。它去年出版，是我读过的关于罗马不列颠最好的书。我强烈推荐给每个人。他把这些硬币描述得非常美。他称它们为“幻觉般的盲文小片”，我绝对喜欢。我的意思是，任何摸过它的人都会立刻明白他的意思。最终，这些硬币不是源自罗马人，而是源自希腊人，
and specifically from the Macedonians. So they are based on coins issued by Philip II, the father of Alexander the Great. So this particular coin that shows a charioteer on one side, Apollo on the other, and they've slowly spread across Europe. And by the time they reach Britain, they're essentially just abstractions. You can barely make out what they originally were. You have those abstracted renderings of the chari and then leaves, you also have the names of people and also amazingly of places. So I'll give three examples of coins that give us specific names and what that can tell us about the situation in Britain before Claudius' invasion. One of them is minted by a people we've already heard of called the Trinovantes. So they're in Essex, kind of moving towards where London would now be. And you get coins minted there from about 35 BC, so 20 years after Caesar's expedition,
具体来说是马其顿人。所以它们是以腓力二世（亚历山大大帝的父亲）发行的硬币为基础的。这枚特殊的硬币一面显示着战车驭手，另一面显示着阿波罗，它们慢慢传遍了欧洲。当它们到达不列颠时，基本上只剩下抽象图案了。你几乎辨认不出它们最初是什么。你有战车的抽象渲染，然后是树叶，你还有人名，甚至令人惊异地还有地名。因此，我将举出三个硬币的例子，它们给出了特定的名字，以及这能告诉我们关于克劳狄入侵前不列颠局势的什么情况。其中之一是由我们已经听说过的一个被称为特里诺万特斯（Trinovantes）的民族铸造的。所以在埃塞克斯，有点走向现在的伦敦。你在那里可以找到大约公元前35年开始铸造的硬币，
by a king called Adedomarus. And this is a guy, we only know his name through his coins. There's no mention of him in any classical sources. He's the king of the Trinovantes. And what we can tell from his coins is that he moves his capital from Hertfordshire, so in the west of his kingdom, to Essex, to a place called Camelodunon, which today is Colchester in Essex. So that's all we know about him. We can trace the fact that he's moved his capital and founded this kind of new place. Then we have his neighbor, a king of the Catephalorni, who we again heard about in the previous episode. These are the ones who fought under Cassius Valonus against Caesar. And this is a guy called Tasciophanus. And Dominic, I have one of his coins. It's one of my most precious possessions. It dated to about 25 BC, and it shows him and his son in double
由一位名叫阿德多马鲁斯（Adedomarus）的国王铸造。这是一个家伙，我们只通过他的硬币才知道他的名字。任何古典文献中都没有提到他。他是特里诺万特斯的国王。从他的硬币中我们可以看出，他将首都从赫特福德郡（在他的王国西部）迁到了埃塞克斯一个名叫卡穆洛杜农（Camulodunon）的地方，也就是今天的埃塞克斯郡科尔切斯特。所以这就是我们关于他的全部所知。我们可以追踪到他迁都并建立这个新地方的事实。然后是他的邻居，卡特维劳尼人（Catuvellauni）的一位国王，我们在上一集中也听说过他。这些是在卡西乌斯·维劳努斯（Cassius Vellaunus）领导下与恺撒作战的人。这是一个名叫塔斯奇瓦努斯（Tasciovanus）的家伙。多米尼克，我有一枚他的硬币。它是我最珍贵的财产之一。它可追溯到公元前25年左右，上面展示了他和他的儿子的双面
profile. But the thing that's really amazing about this coin, and the reason I got it, is that next to the faces of these two kings, Tascivanus and his son, you have Latin letters and they spell out V-E-R-U, so Veru, and that's an abbreviation for Verulamion, which is today the city of St. Albans, about 20 miles kind of northwest of London. And this is the very earliest record we have of a British place name from Britain. So it's amazing. The first time you could hold it in your hand, a complete thrill. And purely using the coins, because again, Tascivanus is not mentioned in any classical source, we can see how he's throwing his weight around, how he goes to war with the Trinovantes,
侧面像。但这枚硬币真正神奇的地方，也是我得到它的原因，是在这两位国王（塔斯奇瓦努斯和他的儿子）的脸旁，有拉丁字母，它们拼写出 V-E-R-U，也就是 Veru，这是 Verulamion（维鲁兰姆）的缩写，也就是今天的圣奥尔本斯市，大约在伦敦西北20英里左右。这是我们拥有的关于不列颠地名的最早记录。所以这太神奇了。你第一次能把它握在手里，绝对是一种激动。而且完全是利用硬币，因为同样地，塔斯奇瓦努斯没有在任何古典文献中被提及，我们可以看到他是如何耀武扬威的，他是如何与特里诺万特斯开战的，
how for a brief period from about 15 to 10 BC, he's issuing coins from Camulodunon, so presumably he's conquered it, and then he gets thrown out. There's a war. He retreats again. So you can see there's war between these two tribes purely on the basis of the coins. And then the third one is our friend Commius, who we mentioned in the previous episode, Caesar's kind of slippery ally, who's always kind of switching sides. He becomes king of the Atrabartes in the south of the Catecholoniae. And he's probably the first king to issue coins with his name on in Britain. And to listeners, you know, they may seem just kind of weird names, these weird tribes, difficult to get a handle on. But just to emphasise, I mean, this is amazing because this is
在大约公元前15年到公元前10年的短暂时期内，他是如何在卡穆洛杜农发行硬币的，所以大概他征服了这里，然后他又被赶出去了。发生了一场战争。他再次撤退。所以纯粹根据硬币，你可以看到这两个部落之间存在战争。第三个是我们的朋友科米乌斯（Commius），我们在上一集中提到过他，恺撒那个圆滑的盟友，总是不断转换立场。他成为卡特维劳尼人南部阿特雷巴特人（Atrebates）的国王。他可能是第一个在不列颠发行印有自己名字的硬币的国王。对于听众来说，（这些）可能只是一些奇怪的名字，这些奇怪的部落，很难弄懂。但我要强调的是，我的意思是，这太神奇了，因为这是
where British history based on British sources begins. Think of all the British political rivalries that we've talked about. This is the earliest evidence from a British source for that long tradition of political rivalry that we have. This is the Johnson, Truss and Sunak of their day, Tom. Yeah. Unbelievably exciting. What a glorious progression that is. Indeed. Progress, progress. So what you have essentially in the southeast of Britain is a three-way contest, three rival groupings, three rival kings. And over the course of the decades that follow, so through the Augustan period, under
以不列颠来源为基础的不列颠历史的开始。想想我们讨论过的所有不列颠政治竞争。这是不列颠政治竞争长期传统的、来自不列颠本土来源的最早证据。这是他们那个时代的约翰逊（Johnson）、特拉斯（Truss）和苏纳克（Sunak），汤姆。是的。令人难以置信的兴奋。多么辉煌的演变啊。确实如此。进步，进步。因此，你在不列颠东南部基本上拥有的是一场三方争夺战，三个竞争的集团，三个竞争的国王。在接下来的几十年里，也就是通过奥古斯都时期，在
Tiberius, under Caligula, you can use these coins to work out for the first time the course of politics in an area of Britain. And the big story is the re-emergence to supremacy of the Catephaloni, the guys who occupy the home counties. And as they expand, so the Trinovantes to the east and the Atrobatis to the south are slowly eclipsed. And the key figure in this rise to greatness is the son of Tasciovannus, who's a man called Cnobolin. So he is the Kimberline of Shakespeare's play. His name seems to mean strong dog, which is a very good name. And he, as his father had done, but this time permanently, subdues the Trinovantes and makes Camulodunum his kind of permanent headquarters, his permanent capital. And meanwhile, his brother is expanding
提比略和卡利古拉统治下，你可以利用这些硬币首次弄清不列颠某个地区的政治走向。而最大的故事是卡特维劳尼人的重新崛起并占绝对优势，这些人占据了伦敦周边的郡县。随着他们的扩张，东部的特里诺万特斯和南部的阿特雷巴特斯慢慢被黯然失色。而这一崛起过程中的关键人物是塔斯奇瓦努斯的儿子，一个名叫库诺巴林（Cunobelin）的人。所以他就是莎士比亚戏剧中的辛白林（Cymbeline）。他的名字似乎意味着“强壮的狗”，这是一个非常好的名字。正如他的父亲所做的那样，但他这次是永久性地，征服了特里诺万特斯，并使卡穆洛杜农成为他永久的总部、他永久的首都。与此同时，他的弟弟正在向南
southwards into the lands of the Atrobaties. And Cunabalin is so successful that even the Suetonius, the Roman biographer, he refers to him as king of the Britons simply. He's seen as the domineering figure in Britain. And when he dies in about AD 40, he's succeeded by his two sons, one of whom is called Togodumnus, who seems to have been centered in Beryllian and Camulodunum, so he's got that tranche. And Togedumnus' brother is a man called Caraticus, and Caraticus continues with the conquest of the Atrabartes, so moving south. And within a year or so of Cunabalin's death, Caraticus has cornered the king of the Atrabartes around where Chichester is now, so that's down by
扩张到阿特雷巴特人的土地上。库诺巴林的成功如此巨大，以至于连罗马传记作家苏埃托尼乌斯（Suetonius）都简单地称他为不列颠人的国王。他被视为不列颠呼风唤雨的人物。当他在公元40年左右去世时，他的两个儿子继承了他的衣钵，其中一个名叫托戈杜姆努斯（Togodumnus），他似乎以维鲁兰姆和卡穆洛杜农为中心，所以他拥有那一块领地。托戈杜姆努斯的兄弟是一个名叫卡拉蒂库斯（Caratacus）的人，卡拉蒂库斯继续对阿特雷巴特人进行征服，因此向南移动。在库诺巴林死后的一两年内，卡拉蒂库斯将阿特雷巴特人的国王逼到了现在奇切斯特（Chichester）周围的角落里，也就是在
Portsmouth Harbour. There's a peninsula, it's protected by great dikes, and this is the last holdout of the Atrobatic king. Caratacus forces his way through, the Atrobatic king flees across the channel, and the name of this king, based on his coins, is Verica. And this almost certainly is the Bericus who is mentioned by Dio in that section that you read. So there's a merging of the evidence from British coins and the classical sources. Right. Bericus, who had been forced into exile by a coup against him and had persuaded Claudius to send an army against the Britons. So says Cassius Dio, and that matches the coin evidence. That's fascinating. So Caraticus is the first character in British history that I remember ever studying. He's perceived as a sort of freedom fighter. But before we turn to Caraticus, so Bericus,
朴茨茅斯港（Portsmouth Harbour）附近。那里有一个半岛，由巨大的堤防保护，这是阿特雷巴特国王的最后一个据点。卡拉蒂库斯强行突围，阿特雷巴特国王逃过海峡，根据他的硬币，这位国王的名字叫维里卡（Verica）。这几乎可以肯定是狄奥在他读的那段中提到的贝里库斯。因此，来自不列颠硬币的证据与古典文献的证据融合在了一起。没错。贝里库斯因一场针对他的政变而被流放，并说服克劳狄派遣军队讨伐不列颠人。卡西乌斯·狄奥如是说，这与硬币的证据相吻合。这太迷人了。所以卡拉蒂库斯是我记忆中最早学习的不列颠历史人物。他被视为某种自由斗士。但在我们转向卡拉蒂库斯之前，关于贝里库斯，
you see Bericus as a sort of, he's like Ambassador Graham Martin fleeing the US embassy in Saigon in 1975. Explain to me that analogy, Tom. Karatekus becomes a freedom fighter, but before that, he's very keen on conquering people. The Britons are perfectly capable of engaging in imperialism themselves. And when he conquers the last holdout, this tip of land on the south coast, surrounded by dikes. So it's a bit like the wall surrounding the US embassy in Saigon. And the reason I make that comparison is because of an extraordinary discovery that was made about a hundred years ago. And this is a Roman helmet encrusted with oysters, had clearly been lying in the harbour for centuries and centuries. And it's
你把贝里库斯看作是某种……他就像1975年在西贡逃离美国大使馆的大使格雷厄姆·马丁（Graham Martin）。汤姆，请向我解释这个类比。卡拉蒂库斯成了自由斗士，但在那之前，他非常热衷于征服别人。不列颠人自己完全有能力参与帝国主义。当他征服最后一个据点时，即南海岸这块被堤防包围的土地。所以这有点像包围西贡美国大使馆的墙。我做这个类比的原因是因为大约一百年前有一个非凡的发现。这是一顶镶嵌着牡蛎的罗马头盔，显然在港口里躺了几个世纪之久。它是
a make that is pre-Claudian invasion. So it must have been there in the decades at some point before the Roman invasion, which implies a Roman military presence at the court of Veracus or Verica, whatever you want to call him. So you could kind of imagine a Roman military guard perhaps escorting Veracus, whatever you want to call him. This would be seen as a kind of humiliation for Rome to lose one of their client kings in this way. And it would absolutely provide a kind of casus belli, I think, a kind of justification
克劳狄入侵前制造的。所以它必然在罗马入侵前的几十年的某个时候就在那里了，这意味着在维拉库斯（Veracus）或维里卡（Verica）——无论你想怎么称呼他——的宫廷里存在着罗马的军事存在。所以你可以想象一个罗马军事卫队可能在护送维拉库斯或维里卡。这将被视为对罗马的一种羞辱，因为失去了以这种方式依附他们的客户国王（client kings）。我认为这绝对会为入侵提供某种“战争借口”（casus belli），即某种正当理由。
for the invasion. So if that's the case, right, if the Romans had military advisors with this guy, Vericus, who's been attacked by Caraticus, does that imply that in the century since Julius Caesar came and went, that the contacts have not just continued, but possibly deepened so that the Romans have client kings, they have their patronage, they are sending military advisors to Britain. And the only reason it's not recorded is we don't really have that many sources. There are particular sources that record that have been lost. You're right. I mean, we have very few sources. We do have kind of the occasional tangential allusion to the fact that British kings are always being expelled and kind of going to Rome and asking for help. So Augustus, for instance, he has this great thing of the raised guest diet. It's basically his kind of, you know, his CV, all his achievements. And he describes the British king coming to him and asking for help. And there's also a sense, I think, that these
如果真是这样，好吧，如果罗马人有军事顾问陪伴这个遭到卡拉蒂库斯攻击的家伙维里卡，这是否意味着在尤利乌斯·恺撒来去之间的一个世纪里，联系不仅没有中断，而且可能加深了，以至于罗马人有了附庸国国王，有了他们的庇护权，他们正在向不列颠派遣军事顾问。而之所以没有被记录下来，只是因为我们没有那么多的源头。有些特定的记录源头已经丢失了。你是对的。我的意思是，我们的源头很少。我们确实有那种偶然的、切线式的暗示，即不列颠国王总是在被驱逐，然后跑到罗马寻求帮助。比如奥古斯都，他有这件伟大的事情，即《奥古斯都功业录》（Res Gestae Divi Augusti）。这基本上就是他的，你知道的，他的履历，他所有的成就。他描述了不列颠国王来找他寻求帮助。而且我还认为有一种感觉，这些
British kings are sending their sons as hostages to Rome. We have an account by Strabo, the geographer who's writing in the time of Augustus. He says he saw them. He says, I saw in Rome young men from Britain who were taller even than the Gauls and taller than the tallest Roman by half a foot, but they were bandy-legged and most uncouth in appearance. And you have to wonder whether this is where, you know, the Trinovantes or the Catephaloni are getting their taste for coins from, from princes who've been raised in Rome
不列颠国王把他们的儿子作为人质送到罗马。我们有地理学家斯特拉博（Strabo）的记述，他在奥古斯都时代写作。他说他亲眼见到了他们。他说：“我在罗马看到了来自不列颠的年轻人，他们甚至比高卢人还要高，比最高的罗马人还要高上半英尺，但他们罗圈腿，外表极为粗野。”你不得不怀疑，这是否就是特里诺万特斯或卡特维劳尼人对硬币的品味的来源，来自于在罗马长大、带着对葡萄酒的品味、对某种事物的品味以及对将自己的名字印在硬币上的品味回到不列颠的王子们。
and who are going back with a taste for wine, a taste for whatever, and a taste for stamping their names taste for whatever, and a taste for stamping their names on coins. And on the point about the contacts, so Caligula had talked about attacking Britain, hadn't he? He had amassed his army in this very famous episode. Again, anyone who's read I Claudius or the Suetonius will know this very well. He amasses his army. They think they're going to invade Britain, but actually he says, no, we're going to humiliate Neptune and they all gather seashells. Did that really happen or was that just anti-collegial propaganda?
关于联系这一点，卡利古拉曾谈到过进攻不列颠，不是吗？他在这个非常著名的事件中集结了他的军队。同样，任何读过《我，克劳狄》或苏埃托尼乌斯的人都会非常清楚这一点。他集结了军队。他们以为要去入侵不列颠，但实际上他说，不，我们要羞辱海神（Neptune），然后他们都去收集贝壳。这真的发生了，还是这只是反卡利古拉的宣传？
Come to that in a minute. I mean, the context for that is Cunabalin's conquests in the lands of the Trinovantes and the Atropates, both of whom are allies of Rome. And so Cunabalin, by doing this, is breaking all kinds of treaties that presumably he had signed with Rome. So Tiberius, for instance, had been sending him lots of gold. So this is a standing provocation. And I don't think there's much doubt that Caligula thinks, well, this is absolutely justification enough for an invasion. His reputation is that he's kind of mad, absolutely lunatic, but actually he makes very, very sensible preparations. So in Germany, he recruits two entire new legions so that he can take two legions from the German frontier to Britain, and there won't be a kind of threat to the Rhine frontier. And he also builds a huge
我们一会儿再谈这个。我的意思是，这背后的背景是库诺巴林在特里诺万特斯和阿特雷巴特人土地上的征服，这两个民族都是罗马的盟友。因此，库诺巴林这样做，打破了他可能与罗马签署的各种条约。例如，提比略曾向他发送大量黄金。所以这是一个长期的挑衅。我并不怀疑卡利古拉认为，这绝对是入侵的充分理由。他的名声是他有点疯狂，绝对是个疯子，但实际上他做出了非常、非常明智的准备。所以在日耳曼，他招募了两个全新的军团，以便他可以把日耳曼边境的两个军团调往不列颠，同时莱茵河边境也不会受到威胁。他还建造了一个巨大的
lighthouse at what's now Boulogne that can spill its light out across the channel. He's building up naval facilities. He's beefing up his military resources. He seems to be behaving quite well, which makes the whole story about why he orders his soldiers to pick up shells absolutely baffling. I don't really know what the answer is. The best suggestion I can come up with is that perhaps there was a mutiny under Caligula as well, and that Caligula didn't want to acknowledge this because it would be damaging for his prestige. And so this is why he does the whole Neptune shell picking. It's really difficult to know, but whatever the precise explanation for what's going on there, I think it is clear that Caligula's preparations had provided Claudius, who succeeds Caligula when Caligula's assassinated, with the perfect opportunity to
灯塔，位于现在的滨海布洛涅（Boulogne），可以将光芒投射到海峡对岸。他正在建设海军设施。他正在增强他的军事资源。他似乎表现得相当好，这使得关于他为什么命令士兵捡贝壳的整个故事变得完全令人费解。我真的不知道答案是什么。我能想到的最好的建议是，也许卡利古拉手下也发生了哗变，而卡利古拉不想承认这一点，因为这会损害他的威望。所以这就是他进行整个捡海神贝壳的原因。这真的很难知道，但无论那里究竟发生了什么精确的解释，我认为很明显，卡利古拉的准备工作为在卡利古拉被暗杀后继承其位的克劳狄提供了绝佳的机会
launch this invasion. He has the justification, because the Catecholoni have been behaving badly to his allies. He has the opportunity, because he has all these additional legions that have been recruited. He has all this naval infrastructure. And he has the motivation, because he needs to establish himself and burnish his prestige. And so it is in the early summer of AD 43, after his freedmen has come and has suppressed the revolt, and they've all had a
发动这场入侵。他有正当理由，因为卡图维劳尼人（Catecholoni）对他的盟友们态度恶劣。他有这个机会，因为他招募了所有这些额外的军团。他拥有所有的海军基础设施。他有这个动机，因为他需要建立自己的地位并提升威望。因此，在公元43年初夏，在他的释放民前来平定叛乱、众人对此开怀大笑之后，
good laugh about it, that some 30,000 to 40,000 men, so either three or four legions plus auxiliary troops, set sail from Boulogne. They're pulling out from the harbour beneath the great glow of the lighthouse built by Caligula. They sail out into the channel, and when they pulling out from the harbour beneath the great glow of the lighthouse built by Caligula. They sail out into the channel and when they get out there, they're blown off course by contrary winds. Everyone starts feeling seasick, terrified, thinking the worst,
大约有3万到4万名士兵——也就是三到四个军团加上辅助部队——从滨海布洛涅（Boulogne）扬帆起航。他们驶离了由卡利古拉（Caligula）建造的宏伟灯塔的光芒之下的港口。他们驶入海峡，当他们驶离港口、沐浴在卡利古拉建造的宏伟灯塔的光芒中时，他们驶入海峡，到了那里，却被逆风吹离了航线。每个人都开始晕船，惊恐万分，做最坏的打算，
dreading sea monsters. But then high up in the sky, they see a shooting star and it's rising in the east and it's falling in the west over the island of Britain. And Dio, who reports this, says of this remarkable occurrence that the soldiers took it as an omen of success.
畏惧海怪。但随后，在夜空高处，他们看到了一颗流星，它在东方升起，并在不列颠岛上空的西方落下。报道这一事件的狄奥（Dio）说，对于这个非同寻常的现象，士兵们认为这是成功的预兆。
Well, Tom, as we all know, a portent in the sky can mean good fortune or it can mean humiliation and disaster. So listeners should come back after the break to find out which it is. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment. early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com
好了，汤姆，众所周知，天上的异象既意味着好运，也可能意味着羞辱和灾难。所以听众朋友们休息之后记得回来，看看究竟是哪一种。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一抹娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。
welcome back to the rest is history tom we entered the first half with the portent in the sky the comet or whatever it is i'm sure that definitely happened by the way yeah dipping over the western horizon and was it an omen of good fortune? That is the question. It was. Oh, great. So they're not shipwrecked. They make an unopposed landing. It's not absolutely clear exactly how they make their landing. So Dio says they make it in three waves. So that might be their landing in one place in succession, or it might be that they're kind of making three beachheads. One of them certainly is by the Isle of Thanet. That's the rule. You've got to go there. And it's on an island that is just between the Isle of Thanet
欢迎回到《历史至上》，汤姆。我们在前半部分提到了天上的异象，那颗彗星或其他什么东西——顺便说一句，我确信这绝对发生过——划过西方地平线。这究竟是不是好运的预兆？这就是问题所在。是的。哦，太好了。所以他们没有遭遇海难。他们进行了未受阻挠的登陆。目前尚不完全清楚他们是如何登陆的。狄奥说他们分三波登陆。所以这可能是他们在一个地方连续登陆，或者也可能是他们在建立三个滩头阵地。其中一个肯定是在萨尼特岛（Isle of Thanet）附近。这是常规操作，你必须去那里。它位于萨尼特岛
and the mainland in this channel called the Wantsum Channel on this island, which is easily connectable to the mainland, which becomes the great naval base of Ritu Pai or Richborough, as it's called now. And the Romans do their usual stuff. They build ditches, establish it as a supply base. But it's possible that they also send contingents to the region in Chichester, which had been the stronghold of the Atrabartes. Because if you remember, the shooting star described by Dio is coming from the east to the west. And Dio says that they were sailing in the direction of the soldiers they saw that. So perhaps, you know, that's one of the landing places. And the other landing place, I don't know, maybe in Sussex, something like that. We don't know.
与大陆之间的一个岛屿上，这个海峡被称为万斯姆海峡（Wantsum Channel）。这个岛屿很容易与大陆相连，后来成为了里图帕埃（Ritu Pai）或现在所谓的里奇伯勒（Richborough）的大型海军基地。罗马人做着他们常做的事：他们修建沟渠，将其建立为一个补给基地。但他们也可能向奇切斯特（Chichester）地区派遣了分遣队，那里曾是阿特雷巴特人（Atrabartes）的大本营。因为如果你还记得的话，狄奥描述的那颗流星是从东向西移动的。狄奥说，士兵们看到流星时，正朝着那个方向航行。所以也许，你知道，那是登陆地点之一。至于另一个登陆地点，我不知道，也许在苏塞克斯郡（Sussex）之类的地方。我们不得而知。
But what is clear is that bridgeheads are established and a two-pronged invasion is launched against the Catavoloni. So heading up towards the Thames. Some are going up from the south coast, the lands of the Atrobatis. Others are moving from the Isle of Thanet across Kent. There's a great battle probably at the Medway. One of the Roman officers who performs very well there is a man called Vespasian. He's in charge of the Second Legion. A name to conjure with. Yeah.
但显而易见的是，桥头堡已经建立，针对卡图维劳尼人的两路夹击入侵已经展开。他们正朝着泰晤士河进发。一部分人从南海岸阿特雷巴特人的土地出发向上推进；另一部分人则从萨尼特岛横跨肯特郡（Kent）。梅德韦河（Medway）上可能爆发了一场大战。在那里表现非常出色的罗马军官之一是一个名叫韦斯帕芗（Vespasian）的人。他负责指挥第二军团。这是一个响亮的名字。是的。
And he also has these very impressive German mercenaries called the Batavians, these auxiliaries who are serving the Romans. They have the very estimable ability to cross rivers in full armor. They swim across the Medway probably and catch the Britons in the rear. It's a very bloody contest, but the Romans managed to force their way across the river. Then they rendezvous with the other prong of the attack on the banks of the Thames. They cross the Thames, probably in the vicinity of London, probably building the bridge that will become London Bridge, forcing
他手下还有这些令人印象深刻的德国雇佣兵——巴达维亚人（Batavians），这些为罗马人效力的辅助部队。他们拥有在全副武装的情况下过河的非凡能力。他们可能会游过梅德韦河，从后方袭击不列颠人。这是一场非常血腥的战斗，但罗马人设法强渡了这条河。然后，他们在泰晤士河畔与另一路进攻部队会合。他们渡过了泰晤士河，可能是在伦敦附近，可能修建了日后成为伦敦桥的桥梁，强行
their way across. And they defeat the combined forces of the two sons of Cunabalin, Caraticus and Togodumnus. And the question then is what happens to those two men? Caraticus flees westwards and inland. And you talked about him, he will become the great resistance fighter. That's where he's going. He is going to try and raise tribes in the interior of Britain against the threat of the Roman advance to kind of open their eyes to what is coming. Togdamnus is more intriguing. So Dio says that he dies in the battle, but it's been argued that Dio was mistranslating a word in Latin and that perhaps Togdamnus survived. The reason for that is that Tacitus, who is the other great historian of this period who gives us a kind of balancing narrative, he describes a king called Togidubnus,
渡河。他们击败了库诺贝林（Cunobalin）的两个儿子卡拉蒂库斯（Caraticus）和托戈杜姆努斯（Togodumnus）的联军。接下来的问题是，这两个人的结局如何？卡拉蒂库斯向西逃往内陆。你之前谈到过他，他将成为伟大的抵抗战士。他就是去那里的。他试图在不列颠内陆挑起各部落反抗罗马人进军的威胁，让他们睁开眼睛看看即将发生的事情。托戈杜姆努斯则更耐人寻味。狄奥说他在战斗中阵亡了，但也有人认为狄奥是误译了一个拉丁语单词，也许托戈杜姆努斯活了下来。原因在于，作为这个时期另一位提供平衡叙事的伟大历史学家，塔西陀（Tacitus）描述了一位名叫托吉杜布努斯（Togidubnus）的国王，
who rules the lands of the Atrabates as a loyal ally of Rome for decades. He's also called Togidubnus in his descriptions. But the names are so similar. They're so similar. And so it's become quite a popular theory. I mean, not universally accepted, but lots of scholars give it credence, that perhaps this is what happened to him, that rather than dying, he was turned, that he became a collaborator with the Romans. And if that's the case, then the fate of the two brothers, Caraticus and Togedumnus, illustrates essentially the two alternatives that are open to the British elites, either to continue resistance or to collaborate. What's clear is that for the
他在接下来的几十年里作为罗马的忠实盟友统治着阿特雷巴特人的土地。在塔西陀的描述中，他也叫托吉杜布努斯。但这两个名字太相似了。它们太相似了。因此，这成了一个非常流行的理论——虽然并非普遍被接受，但许多学者认为它可信——也许这就是他的结局：他没有战死，而是归顺了，成了罗马人的合作者。如果是这样的话，那么卡拉蒂库斯和托戈杜姆努斯这两个兄弟的命运，本质上说明了摆在不列颠精英面前的两条可选道路：要么继续抵抗，要么合作。显而易见的是，对于
Catecholomeo, the vast mass of the Catecholomeo, they don't really have an option. Their resistance has been broken. Aulus Plautius, who's on the far side of the Thames now, halts because he knows that he has fulfilled his mission, which is to prepare the way for Claudius to come to Britain and lay claim to a great victory. So the word reaches Rome. Claudius leaves Rome. He sails up to Marseilles from Ostia, the port of Rome, crosses Gaul, arrives in Richebrough, Ritupiae, and comes up and joins all as Plautius. And they then advance on Camulodunum, which effectively has been cast by the Romans as the capital, not just of the Catephalornae, but of Britain. Camelodunon is a dump. So Shepard Freer in his Great History of Britain,
卡图维劳尼人（Catecholomeo）——绝大多数卡图维劳尼人来说，他们其实别无选择。他们的抵抗已经被粉碎。现在身处泰晤士河对岸的奥卢斯·普劳蒂乌斯（Aulus Plautius）停了下来，因为他知道自己已经完成了使命，那就是为克劳迪乌斯（Claudius）来不列颠并宣称取得伟大胜利铺平道路。于是消息传到了罗马。克劳迪乌斯离开罗马。他从罗马港口奥斯蒂亚（Ostia）乘船北上到达马赛，穿过高卢，抵达里奇伯勒（Richeborough / Ritupiae），然后北上与奥卢斯·普劳蒂乌斯会合。随后，他们向卡穆洛杜努姆（Camulodunum）进发，这座城市实际上已被罗马人塑造成了不仅是卡图维劳尼人，而且是整个不列颠的首都。卡穆洛杜努姆简直是个垃圾堆。因此，谢泼德·弗里尔（Shepard Frere）在他的《不列颠伟大历史》中，
she wrote several decades ago, but I don't think there's any particular reason to change his judgment on it. The habitations, he wrote, were for the most part small huts of prehistoric character. So nothing that a Roman emperor would find very impressive. But Claudius doesn't care because he's got his victory. And so he makes a splendid triumphal entry. He's brought the Praetorians. He's probably, although again, inevitably there are scholars who dispute this, but I think probably he has elephants. So this is all very impressive. Well, they've obviously shipped them across the channel. The evidence, I think, suggests that. It's capable of being read different ways, but I think probably, yes, he's brought elephants
虽然是他几十年前写的，但我认为没有特别的理由改变他对该地的评价。他写道，这里的住所大多是史前风格的小屋。所以罗马皇帝绝对不会觉得这有什么了不起。但克劳迪乌斯不在乎，因为他已经赢得了胜利。因此，他进行了一场盛大的凯旋入城式。他带来了禁卫军。虽然同样不可避免地有一些学者对此提出异议，但我认为他很可能带了大象。所以这一切都非常令人印象深刻。好吧，他们显然是用船把大象运过海峡的。我认为有证据表明确实如此。虽然对此可以有不同的解读，但我认为大概是的，他把大象带了
with him and he duly receives the submission of 11 British kings, including, if a subsequent record is correct, a king from Orkney, so miles in the north of Scotland. So impressive. So before we just get on to Claudius and the time he spends in Britain, two questions. Number one, you talk about breaking the British resistance. Presumably the Romans, I mean, as we've said, an incredibly professional army, technologically the most advanced army in the kind of Eurasian world. And the Britons, they've got their moustaches, they've got their javelins.
过来，并且理所当然地接受了11位不列颠国王的臣服，其中如果后来的记录准确的话，甚至包括一位来自奥克尼（Orkney）的国王——也就是苏格兰远北地区的国王。太惊人了。那么，在我们继续探讨克劳迪乌斯及其在不列颠度过的时间之前，有两个问题。第一，你谈到了粉碎不列颠人的抵抗。据我推测，罗马人——正如我们所说——是一支极其专业的军队，在欧亚大陆的世界里，他们是技术最先进的军队。而不列颠人呢，他们留着八字胡，拿着标枪。
They've got their slings. They've got their slings and their chariots. But presumably just a pitiful force by comparison. They're not pitiful. The charge of a British army is terrifying. If you can withstand it, then you will probably win. And Roman professional training is all about conditioning soldiers to withstand a charge like that.
他们有投石索。他们有投石索和战车。但相比之下，他们大概只是一支可怜的军队吧？他们并不可怜。不列颠军队的冲锋是极其恐怖的。如果你能顶住它，你很可能会赢。而罗马职业训练的核心就是让士兵经受住这种冲锋的考验。
And of course, giving them the kind of armour and kit that will enable them to do it. So here's the thing. Do the Britons have swords? They have swords, yes. Very impressive swords. Ah, interesting. Which they seem to have offered as offerings to the gods, to the various rivers where they've been dredged,
当然，还要给他们配备能够做到这一点的铠甲和装备。所以问题来了：不列颠人有剑吗？他们有剑，是的。非常令人印象深刻的剑。啊，有趣。他们似乎把这些剑作为祭品献给神灵，扔进了他们曾被疏浚过的各种河流中，
which is why you can now go and see them in museums. And my second question, Aulus Plautius is a general, obviously. He's commanded the army. Claudius has not commanded it. Is that not an issue for Claudius with the whole prestige thing and being an imperator? It doesn't matter. No, it's like Caesar. It's all about the story. It's all about the spin that he can give it. And when he goes back to Rome, he really does spin it.
这就是为什么你现在可以去博物馆里看到它们。我的第二个问题是，奥卢斯·普劳蒂乌斯显然是一位将军。他指挥了军队。克劳迪乌斯并没有亲自指挥。对于克劳迪乌斯来说，考虑到整个威望问题以及作为一个统帅（imperator）的身份，这难道不是个问题吗？这没关系。不，这就像恺撒一样。这全都是关于故事本身。这完全关乎他能给出的舆论包装。当他回到罗马时，他确实进行了大肆的包装宣传。
So there are celebrations across the empire. In Rome, he celebrates a triumph. So, you know, this great parade through the streets of Rome, he gets given the name of Britannicus. There's a huge triumphal arch. He restages the conquest of Camulodunum, as the Romans called Camulodunum, in a gladiatorial display. They've brought Britons who ride chariots and everything. It's like Buffalo Bill, only people actually get killed as part of the display. So he's all over it. And you get a sense of how this then gets promoted across the empire from a city called Aphrodisias in what's now Turkey, where there's a very celebrated frieze of Claudius. He's got an absolute six-pack. There's no hint that he might have trouble walking. He's an absolute brute. He's holding the first representation of Britannia as a female. He's forced her down to her knees.
因此，整个帝国都在庆祝。在罗马，他庆祝了一场凯旋式。所以，你知道，通过罗马街道的那场盛大游行，他被授予了“不列颠尼库斯”（Britannicus）的称号。这里有一座巨大的凯旋门。他在角斗表演中重现了对卡穆洛杜努姆（罗马人对卡穆洛杜努姆的称呼）的征服。他们带来了驾驶战车的不列颠人以及各种各样的人。这就像水牛比尔（Buffalo Bill）的表演，只不过作为表演的一部分，真的有人会死。所以他把这一切都拿捏得死死的。你可以从土耳其境内现名阿弗罗迪西亚斯（Aphrodisias）的一座城市中，感受到这一切是如何在整个帝国得到宣传的。那里有一幅非常著名的克劳迪乌斯浮雕。他有着绝对的六块腹肌。完全没有迹象表明他走路可能有困难。他是一个绝对的猛男。他手里抓着第一个女性形象的不列颠尼亚（Britannia）。他把她强行按倒在膝盖上，
Her tunic has been pulled off her breasts. And it's pretty clear what Claudius is about to do to her. And the Romans don't really have any compunction in celebrating the fact that what they're doing to Britain is raping it. There is an element of seduction. So if Togedubnus has become the king of this kind of client kingdom in the south, then he's very, very richly rewarded. There's a great villa there called Fishbourne, which lots of scholars, again, think was given to Togedubnus as a kind of reward. It's the equivalent of Indian princes buying Rolls Royces for their palaces, sending their sons to Harrow, that kind of thing. He's being given the best that the Roman Empire can give in terms of material culture and prestige.
她的束腰外衣被从胸前扯下。克劳迪乌斯接下来要对她做什么显而易见。罗马人对于庆祝他们对不列颠所做的事其实就是强奸，没有任何心理负担。这里面确实有一种诱惑的成分。因此，如果托吉杜布努斯成为了南部这种附庸王国国王，那么他将获得极其丰厚的奖赏。那里有一座宏观的别墅，名叫菲什伯恩（Fishbourne），许多学者同样认为这是送给托吉杜布努斯的某种奖励。这相当于印度王公为他们的宫殿购买劳斯莱斯、把儿子送到哈罗公学（Harrow）那种级别的待遇。罗马帝国在物质文化和威望方面能给予的最好的东西，他都得到了。
So he's got his baths and are hyper-coarsed and marble statues and stuff. Yes. And in a town like Verulamium, so it comes to be called Verulamium by the Romans, within the first years, there are bath complexes being built. There are temples, there are forums, and the baths are the most important because this is a kind of socializing mechanism. So the British elites can go there, they start to wear togas, be acclimatized to the new dispensation. So as I say, if you collaborate, there are rewards on offer. But if you resist, then Roman response is incredibly brutal. So Camulodonum becomes the headquarters of the 20th
所以他有了自己的浴室、火炕道（hypocaust）、大理石雕像之类的东西。是的。在像维鲁兰姆（Verulamium——后来被罗马人这样称呼）这样的城镇里，在最初的几年里，就建成了浴场综合体。那里有神庙、广场，而浴场是最重要的，因为这是一种社交机制。因此，不列颠精英可以去那里，他们开始穿托加长袍，适应新的体制。正如我所说，如果你合作，就会有回报。但如果你抵抗，那么罗马人的反应将是极其残暴的。因此，卡穆洛杜努姆成为了第二0
Legion. The soldiers treat the natives basically as slaves, appropriating their harvests, their livestock, probably their women. In 49, the 20th Legion abandons this base and Camulodonium is transformed into what the Romans called a colonia, which is essentially a transplantation of Rome to a kind of distant territory. It's essentially a showcase for Roman culture. So they built an enormous temple to Claudius, I mean, vast in the way that Durham Cathedral would have appeared vast to the people of the North in the wake of the Norman conquest. And the colonists, the people who settled there, are retired Roman soldiers. And so Tacitus explains the value of this. He says, this constituted a strong body of veterans, a defense against rebels, and a means
军团的总部。士兵们基本上把当地人当作奴隶对待，掠夺他们的收成、牲畜，可能还有他们的女性。49年，第二0军团放弃了这个基地，卡穆洛杜努姆被改造为罗马人所称的“殖民地”（colonia），这本质上是将罗马移植到一个遥远的领土。它本质上是罗马文化的展示橱窗。因此，他们为克劳迪乌斯建造了一座巨大的神庙——在规模上，就像诺曼征服后达勒姆大教堂（Durham Cathedral）在北方人眼中显得极其巨大那样宏伟。而殖民者，即定居在那里的人，是退役的罗马军官。因此，塔西陀解释了这种做法的价值。他说，这构成了一支强大的老兵力量，是抵御叛乱的防线，也是手段
of instilling in our allies respect for our laws. There are no fortifications built around this colonia, Camulodonum, and it reflects the fact that the Romans by this point assume that the southeast is now secured. Meanwhile, legions are fanning out to conquer the rest of Britain. So we can track the advance of one of those generals, Vespasian, who we've mentioned in command command of the Second Legion. He heads into the southwest and Suetonius, who writes a biography of him, says that he brought two very strong tribes under Roman rule, together with over 20 large settlements and Vectis, that's the Isle of Wight, an island just off Britain. Now, Dominic, I don't know if you remember, I always did as a child, that I was always told that this
向我们的盟友灌输对我们法律的尊重。这座殖民地卡穆洛杜努姆周围没有修建任何防御工事，这反映出罗马人此时已经认为东南部现在是安全的了。与此同时，各军团正在向外开枝散叶，以征服不列颠的其他地区。因此，我们可以追踪其中一位将军的进军路线，他就是我们之前提到过的指挥第二军团的韦斯帕芗。他深入西南部，为他写传记的苏埃托尼乌斯（Suetonius）说，他将两个非常强大的部落以及20多个大型定居点和维克蒂斯（Vectis，即怀特岛，不列颠附近的一个岛屿）置于罗马统治之下。多米尼克，我不知道你是否还记得，我小时候总是这样，我总是被告知
included Maiden Castle, which is this enormous hill fort outside Dorchester, the county town of Dorset. This was excavated in the late 1930s by two archaeologists, Mortimer Wheeler and his wife. And his wife died. Mortimer Wheeler then wrote up the report in 1941. And in it, he says how he has identified the Roman conquest, the Roman storming of Maiden Castle, how there'd been this massive artillery barrage. And he says how he's found a ballista bolt bedded in the spine of one of the Britons who were buried there at the
这包括梅登城堡（Maiden Castle），这是多塞特郡（Dorset）郡治多尔切斯特（Dorchester）郊外的一座巨大山堡。这里在20世纪30年代末由两位考古学家——莫蒂默·惠勒（Mortimer Wheeler）和他的妻子——进行了发掘。他的妻子去世后，莫蒂默·惠勒于1941年写出了发掘报告。他在报告中讲述了他是如何识别出罗马对梅登城堡的征服和强攻的，当时曾有密集的炮火轰炸。他说，他在山堡
gateway of the hill fort. And this was still being repeated in the books that I was reading as a kind of Rome-enthusiastic child in the 70s. But sadly, not true. He'd been massively over-interpreting it. There was no military bolt in the spine. And it turns out that Maiden Castle had actually been abandoned decades before the Roman invasion. And if you think about it, anyone who's been to Maiden Castle, it is huge. It's a vast structure.
入口处被埋葬的一名不列颠人的脊椎骨里发现了一枚嵌进去的弩炮箭头。我在70年代作为一个狂热的罗马迷童阅读的书籍中，仍然在重复这种说法。但遗憾的是，这不是真的。他当时进行了极大的过度解读。脊椎里并没有军事弩箭。事实证明，梅登城堡实际上在罗马入侵几十年前就已经被废弃了。如果你仔细想想，任何去过梅登城堡的人都知道，它太大了。这是一个极其庞大的建筑。
It would have been indefensible. There simply it is huge. It's a vast structure. It would have been indefensible. I mean, there simply wouldn't have been enough people to defend it. So it was probably a centre for cultic practices, for the sacral. So Ronald Hutton says that at hill forts, you know, people want to know what did the sacral look like in the British landscape? Look at hill forts. That's probably what they were. But I think that Mortimer Wheeler, he's writing it in 41. He obviously has the experience of the great 20th century wars in his mind. He'd fought in the First World War. He'd go on to fight in the Second World War. He becomes very decorated. And I think that he saw in the Roman conquest a preview of the horrors of 20th century warfare, where you would have artillery barrages and then soldiers going in. And the details may be wrong, but that sense of
它根本无法防御。那里简直——它太大了，是一个庞大的结构。它将是无法防守的。我的意思是，根本没有足够的人手来防守它。所以它可能是一个用于宗教仪式和神圣活动的中心。因此，罗南·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）说，在山堡里，你知道，人们想知道不列颠景观中的神圣事物是什么样子的吗？看看山堡吧。这可能就是它们的真面目。但我认为，莫蒂默·惠勒在41年写下这些时，他的脑海中显然带着20世纪大战的经历。他参加过第一次世界大战，后来又参加了第二次世界大战。他获得了很多勋章。我认为他在罗马的征服中看到了20世纪战争恐怖的缩影，在那里你会经历炮火轰炸，然后士兵冲锋。细节可能并不准确，但那种
mass slaughter, mass enslavement, mass rape, I mean, he's not wrong. That is what's going on. How do we know that these things happened? We can look at, I suppose, the paradigmatic example of this is what happens in Wales. You asked earlier, why are the Romans going to Britain? She fits for the mineral wealth and gold, silver, lead is to be found above all in Wales. And the conquest of Wales, as it was for, say, the English in the Middle Ages, is a very protracted and bloody process. Because of the geography, the hills,
大规模屠杀、大规模奴役、大规模强奸的感觉——我是说，他并没有错。这确实是当时正在发生的事情。我们怎么知道这些事情发生了呢？我们可以看看，我想，这方面的典型例子就是威尔士发生的事件。你之前问过，为什么罗马人要去不列颠？主要是为了矿产资源，金、银、铅主要都在威尔士。而对威尔士的征服，就像中世纪英国人对威尔士的征服一样，是一个非常旷日持久且血腥的过程。因为那里的地理环境：山丘、
the valleys, the forests, all that stuff. So by 47, so Aulus Plautius is recalled to Rome. He doesn't have a triumph because only emperors can have triumphs by this point, but he's given what's called innovation. So it's basically a triumph and you don't ride in a chariot, you walk. He leaves an island, the lowlands of which have been occupied. So in a line from the Humber down to the Aix in Devon. Of course, beyond the frontier is Wales. And Duncan McKay, in his wonderful book on Boudicca, he describes it when the Romans had first landed in Southern Britain, those distant tribes and their brooding cloud hung hills were no more than a darkness beyond the horizon. But when the Romans go into Wales, of course, they're plunging into the darkness as they would see it. And they're confronting two tribal groupings, the Silurians in the south,
山谷、森林，所有这些因素。到了公元47年，奥卢斯·普劳蒂乌斯被召回罗马。他没有举办凯旋式，因为此时只有皇帝才能举办凯旋式，但他被授予了一种名为“椭圆凯旋式”（ovation）的荣誉。这基本上就是凯旋式，只是你不是坐在战车里，而是步行。他离开了一个低地已经被占领的岛屿。即从亨伯（Humber）一直到德文郡埃克斯（Axe）的一条线。当然，前线之外就是威尔士。邓肯·麦凯（Duncan McKay）在他关于波狄卡（Boudicca）的精彩著作中描述了这一点：当罗马人首次登陆不列颠南部时，那些遥远的部落和他们阴云密布的山丘，不过是地平线外的一片黑暗。但当罗马人进入威尔士时，他们当然就像他们所看到的那样，一头扎进了黑暗之中。他们面临着两个部落集团：南部的西卢尔人（Silurians），
so the Silurians, Dominic, as in... Dr. Who. And the Ordovicians in the north. So anyone interested in prehistory and geology will recognise them as periods of the geological past derived from the rocks that you get in the territories of these tribes. And the resistance there is incredibly brutal. And this is partly because Caraticus has made his base there. So that's super interesting. If Caraticus has made his base there, does that imply a kind of shared identity? Because he is a king from a long way away. I mean, days march or walk. Yeah, I agree. It's fascinating. And I think that
所以西卢尔人，多米尼克，就像……《神秘博士》（Dr. Who）里的那样。还有北部的奥尔多维克斯人（Ordovicians）。因此，任何对史前史和地质学感兴趣的人都会从这些部落领地里产出的岩石中认出，这些是地质历史时期的名称。那里的抵抗极其残酷。这部分是因为卡拉蒂库斯在那里建立了基地。所以这超级有趣。如果卡拉蒂库斯在那里建立了基地，这是否意味着某种共同的身份认同？因为他是一个来自很远地方的国王。我的意思是，需要走好几天或 march 好几天。是的，我同意。这太迷人了。我认为
he makes common cause with the tribes in Wales. I mean, Wales is an anachronistic word, but let's call it Wales, the Welsh tribes, because he brings an understanding of how the Romans operate that the Welsh tribes wouldn't have because they don't really know what's about to hit them. It's an alliance of convenience and it's very successful. Caraticus and the Welsh tribes continue their fight until in 51 he's cornered by a Roman army and he's defeated in pitched battle. He flees to the upland regions of what's now the Midlands and Yorkshire, where there's a queen called Cartamandua. And Cartamandua is an ally of the Roman people. And so she hands Caraticus over
他与威尔士的部落志同道合。“威尔士”是一个时代错置的词，但我们就叫它威尔士、威尔士部落吧，因为他带来了对罗马人行事方式的理解，而威尔士部落原本是不会了解的，因为他们根本不知道有什么样的灾难即将降临。这是一场权宜之盟，而且非常成功。卡拉蒂库斯和威尔士部落继续战斗，直到公元51年，他被罗马军队逼入绝境，并在激战中被击败。他逃往现在米德兰兹（Midlands）和约克郡的高地地区，那里有一位名叫卡塔曼杜阿（Cartamandua）的女王。卡塔曼杜阿是罗马人民的盟友。因此，她把卡拉蒂库斯交给了
to the Romans. And this is always cast as an act of the basest treachery. But I think it's probably slightly more complicated than that. And it's probably a bit like she's playing the role that Commius did with Caesar. So she's essentially the kind of, not the middle man, the middle woman who's negotiating terms between the two sides. And so Caraticus is captured. He's taken off to Rome. He's led through the streets in chains. Everyone's terribly impressed by him, his noble bearing, the splendor of his golden moustache, all of that. And Claudius, with an imperious show of magnanimity, orders his chains to be struck off. And Caraticus then wanders around Rome saying, in an inspiring manner, I have no idea why the Romans came to
罗马人。这总是被描绘成一种极其卑鄙的背叛行为。但我认为这可能比这稍微复杂一点。这可能有点像她在扮演当年科米乌斯（Commius）对恺撒扮演的角色。所以她本质上是那种——不是中间人，而是女性中间人——在双方之间谈判条款。于是卡拉蒂库斯被俘虏了。他被带到了罗马。他戴着脚镣被游街示众。每个人都对他的风度、他高贵的仪态、他金色的八字胡的绚丽等等印象深刻。克劳迪乌斯以一种盛气凌人的宽宏大量，下令砸掉他的脚镣。随后卡拉蒂库斯在罗马四处闲逛，以一种鼓舞人心的方式说：“我实在搞不懂罗马人为什么要来
conquer my lands when you have such wealth. Why do you need my mean and backward land when you have such a splendid capital? I remember that story so well from when I was about seven. And I love that because everyone comes out well from that story. Claudius does. Graticus does. I suppose Cartabandua doesn't. No, I guess not.
征服我的土地，既然你们拥有如此巨大的财富。既然你们有这么辉煌的首都，为什么还需要我那贫瘠落后的土地呢？”我对这个故事记忆犹新，大概从我七岁左右开始。我喜欢这个结局，因为每个人在这个故事里都落得个好名声。克劳迪乌斯是，格拉蒂库斯（Graticus）也是。我想卡塔曼杜阿（Cartabandua）大概不是吧。不，我想不是。
She'll be getting up to more mischief in due course, as we will see. But the thing is that in Wales, Graticus' capture doesn't stop the fighting. They carry on. And this may reflect the influence of the Druids who have their base up in Anglesey, Mona. That's another thing that I learned when I was seven that stuck in my mind. Anglesey was full of these wild-haired wizards. And this is true. It is true. What is also true is that there are rumours that spread unsurprisingly through the Welsh tribes that the Romans are intending genocide.
正如我们将看到的，她接下来还会惹出更多的麻烦。但问题是，在威尔士，格拉蒂库斯的被捕并没有停止战斗。他们继续抗争。这可能反映了德鲁伊（Druids）的影响，他们的总部设在安格尔西岛（Anglesey / Mona）。这也是我七岁时学到并留在记忆中的另一件事。安格尔西岛上全是这些头发蓬乱的巫师。这是真的。确实如此。同样属实的是，威尔士部落中毫不意外地开始流传谣言，称罗马人打算进行种族灭绝。
The Silurians in particular are outraged by a report that Plautus' replacement as governor, a man called Ostorius Scapula, had declared that the name of the Silurians should be wiped from the face of the earth. The so the campaign is of a genocidal scope. The Romans are trying to wipe the Silurians out. The Silurians are trying to wipe the Romans out. And in fact, during Scapula's term of office, a legion is so badly mauled, it has to retreat. And that's obviously a kind of devastating blow to Roman prestige. And Scapular actually dies in office, it seems, of the strain. And he's followed by two more governors and they can't pacify the Welsh. The bloodshed continues, the slaughter, the enslavement. And so finally in 58, by which point Claudius has been dead for four years and been succeeded by his young heir Nero, the decision
特别是西卢尔人，他们对一份报告感到愤怒：普劳蒂乌斯的继任总督、一个名叫奥斯托里乌斯·斯库普拉（Ostorius Scapula）的人曾宣称，西卢尔人的名字应该从地球上被抹去。所以这场战役具有种族灭绝的规模。罗马人试图消灭西卢尔人。西卢尔人试图消灭罗马人。事实上，在斯库普拉任职期间，有一个军团遭到惨重打击，不得不撤退。这显然对罗马的威望是一个毁灭性的打击。斯库普拉本人似乎也因压力过大而死于任上。接替他的是另外两位总督，但他们都无法安抚威尔士人。流血、屠杀和奴役仍在继续。因此，最终在公元58年，此时克劳迪乌斯已经去世四年，由他的年轻继承人尼禄（Nero）继位，罗马决定
is taken to send Rome's best general to sort the mess out. And this is a man called Gaius Suetonius Paulinus. And he has experience of fighting in mountains because he had been the governor of Mauritania, so Morocco as it is now. And he'd been the first person to lead a Roman military expedition up into the Atlas mountains, where he'd seen all kinds of wonders. And so he seems absolutely the man for a mountain campaign in the wilds of Britain. And he basically
派其最好的将军去收拾这个烂摊子。这个人名叫盖乌斯·苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯（Gaius Suetonius Paulinus）。他有在山区作战的经验，因为他曾担任过毛里塔尼亚（Mauritania——即现在的摩洛哥）的总督。他是第一个率领罗马军事远征队进入阿特拉斯山脉（Atlas mountains）的人，在那里他见识了各种各样的奇观。因此，他绝对是不列颠荒野中进行山地战的理想人选。他基本上
breaks the Salurians and the Ordovicians. So after two years campaigning, so we're now into AD 60, the Salurians have been crushed so totally that they're not mentioned for at least a couple of decades after Paulinus's term of office. And he also does an Edward I and establishes a great complex of forts in the northern region of Wales, where the Ordovicians have their strongholds. And by building this kind of great network of forts, he is able to target the last stronghold, the last outpost, the great center of druidical practice, the island of Anglesey. And in the summer of AD 60, he marches a force of about 15,000 men. So that's legionaries, his own legion, another legion, auxiliaries, and they stand on the shores of the Menae Strait looking
粉碎了西卢尔人和奥尔多维克斯人。经过两年的战役，时间来到了公元60年，西卢尔人遭到了如此彻底的粉碎，以至于在保利努斯任期结束后的至少几十年里，人们都没有再提起他们。他还效仿爱德华一世（Edward I），在奥尔多维克斯人拥有大本营的威尔士北部地区建立了一座宏伟的堡垒群。通过建立这种庞大的堡垒网络，他能够将目标对准最后一个据点、最后一个前哨、德鲁伊教仪式的伟大中心——安格尔西岛。在公元60年的夏天，他率领大约15000人的军队进军。也就是正规军团、他自己的军团、另一个军团以及辅助部队，他们站在梅奈海峡（Menae Strait）的岸边，眺望
across at Anglesey. And there, Dominic, is the bit that you probably remember from your Ladybird book. I'm just going to read it. It's from Tacitus, isn't it? They're stood along the shore, a diverse line, dense with arms and men and with females running in between in funereal clothing and with tumbling hair. They were flourishing firebrands after the manner of the Furies and druids around about pouring forth ominous prayers with their hands raised to the sky. This is reminiscent of the scene when Caesar had landed more than a century earlier. This image of kind of barbarism, mystical barbarism on the other side of the strait. Except that when Caesar lands, it's warriors that he's confronting.
对面的安格尔西岛。多米尼克，这就是你可能从你的《小瓢虫书》（Ladybird book）中记忆犹新的片段。我打算读一下。这是出自塔西陀，对吧？“他们沿着海岸站成一列，阵形错杂，兵器密布，其间有女性身穿丧服、披头散发地奔跑着。她们挥舞着火把，宛如复仇女神（Furies），德鲁伊们则环绕四周，双手举向天空，不断倾泻着不祥的祈祷。”这让人想起一个多世纪前恺撒登陆时的场景。海峡对岸那种野蛮、神秘野蛮的形象。只不过，当恺撒登陆时，他面对的是战士。
This is wizards, women and wizards. Which in a way makes it more kind of terrifying. Oh, it's definitely, it's absolutely, I'm terrified just thinking about it. It's so vivid. The temptation is to say, oh, he's just made up. How could Tacitus possibly know? I think it has the immediacy of a kind of authentic experience. And we know how Tacitus could have heard about this because Tacitus is
而这次是巫师，女人和巫师。从某种意义上说，这更令人毛骨悚然。哦，绝对的，绝对的，我光是想想就觉得毛骨悚然。太生动了。人们很容易会说：“哦，这全是他编造的。塔西陀怎么可能知道？”但我认为这具有某种真实经历的即视感。而且我们知道塔西陀是如何得知这一点的，因为塔西陀是
the son-in-law of a man called Agricola, who will go on to play a great role in the history of the Roman conquest, but who at the time was a tribune on the staff of Suetonius Paulinus and almost certainly would have described it to Tacitus. I see no particular reason to doubt the general drift of that description, nor the account of what happens, because Paulinus has prepared kind of shallow-bottomed landing craft. His forces managed to get across the Meno Straits. The Britons on Anglesey then are absolute toast, as usual, the mass slaughter, mass enslavement. And it's from Tacitus that we get evidence, I mean, people can believe it to
一个名叫阿格里科拉（Agricola）的人的女婿。阿格里科拉后来在罗马征服不列颠的历史中发挥了巨大作用，但在当时，他是苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯幕僚中的一名军尉（tribune），几乎可以肯定他曾把这些向塔西陀描述过。我看不出有什么特别的理由去怀疑那种描述的大致走向，也不用怀疑所发生事件的记录，因为保利努斯准备了某种底部较浅的登陆艇。他的部队成功渡过了梅奈海峡。安格尔西岛上的不列颠人随后彻底完蛋了，像往常一样，又是大规模屠杀，大规模奴役。正是从塔西陀那里，我们得到了关于人祭的证据——人们可以根据自己的意愿去相信其中的程度。谈到德鲁伊时，塔西陀写道：“他们那些致力于非人迷信的树林被摧毁了。他们确实认为，用俘虏的鲜血涂抹祭坛并通过人类内脏来占卜神意是他们的职责。”所以你可以说这是帝国主义的宣传，或者你可以看看迦太基人或阿兹特克的证据然后说，嗯，为什么不呢？我们不应该把我们对是非对错的分类强加给一个遥远而古老的民族。总的来说，我会说这大概是真的，但我们无法确定。我的意思是，公平地说，我去过北威尔士。我知道你要这么说。
the degree that they want to, of human sacrifice. Talking about the Druids, Tacitus writes, their groves devoted to inhuman superstitions were destroyed. They deemed it indeed a duty to cover their altars with the blood of captives and to consult their deities through human entrails. So you may say this is imperialist propaganda, or you may look at the evidence of the Carthaginians or the Aztecs and say, well, why not? We shouldn't impose our categories of what is right and wrong on a distant and ancient people. On balance, I would say probably, but we can't be certain. I mean, to be fair, I've been to North Wales. I knew you were going to say that.
抱歉，这只是个开场白。是的，我们在那里失去了所有的威尔士听众。作为一个汤姆，我是这样说的。你本身当然也是四分之一威尔士血统。是的，完全正确。所以，绝对可以确定的是，即使那里没有堆满人类内脏的坟墓，这也是一场伟大的胜利，因为看起来终于，整个不列颠南部——也就是默西河（Mersey）和亨伯河以南的线以下——基本上都已经承认了罗马的至高无上地位。而
Sorry, it's just an opening. Yeah, there we lose all our Welsh listeners. And I say that as a man who's Tom. Who is, of course, a quarter Welsh yourself. Yeah, exactly. So what's absolutely certain, even if there aren't graves full of human entrails, this is a great victory because it seems at last, as though all of Southern Britain, so below the line of the Mersey and the Humber, essentially has been brought to acknowledge Roman supremacy. And
苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯，大汗淋漓、血迹斑斑、擦拭着额头的汗水，尽管如此，还是可以大大松一口气，对自己的成就感到无比自豪。然而，多米尼克，就在他凯旋的那个时刻，他刚刚渡过海峡，长途跋涉、精疲力竭，不列颠东南角的一个信使带来了可怕的消息：在不列颠的另一端，一个我们尚未提及的、名叫爱西尼（Icani）的民族已经发动了叛乱，他们正向不列颠的首都、罗马力量的展示橱窗——伟大的殖民地卡穆洛杜努姆进军。最糟糕的是，多米尼克，爱西尼人的首领是一个女人。一个女人？
Suetonius Paulinus, sweaty, bloodstained, wiping his brow, can nevertheless breathe a huge sigh of relief, feel incredibly proud of what he's accomplished. But then, Dominic, in the very hour of his triumph, crossing the straits, travel-stained, exhausted, a messenger from the far southeastern corner of Britain bringing terrible news that on the far side of Britain, a people called the Icani, who we haven't yet mentioned, have risen in revolt, that they are marching on Camulodonium, the great colonia, the capital of Britain, the showcase of Roman power. And worst of all, Dominic, the Icani are led by a woman. A woman?
带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，非常感谢你带来这场精彩绝伦的讲述。这真是悬念中的悬念。我们“历史至上俱乐部”（The Restless History Club）帝国的成员们将立即能够听到接下来发生了什么。剧透一下，这就是波狄卡（Boudicca，如果你喜欢的话也可以叫 Baudicier）的伟大故事，她在许多方面是不列颠人或不列颠不列颠尼亚人对罗马人抵抗的化身。所以如果你是“历史至上俱乐部”的成员，你可以马上收听。如果不是，你可以在 therestishistory.com 注册。如果你不想注册，你就得等到
Well, on that bombshell, Tom, thank you very much for that tour de force. That is the cliffhanger to end all cliffhangers. Members of our own empire, the Restless History Club, will immediately be able to hear what happened next. Spoiler alert, the great story of Boudicca, or Baudicier if you prefer, the embodiment in many ways of British resistance or Brittonic resistance to the Romans. So if you're a member of the Rest is History Club, you can hear that straight away. If you're not, you can sign up at therestishistory.com. And if you don't want to, you'll have to wait until
周一才能知道接下来会发生什么。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一抹娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、
Monday to find out what happens next. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening,
独家加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。那就是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要收听独家加更节目并优先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。